i know you're hurting at the pump gas
prices have hit all-time highs and joe
biden is refusing to allow the oil
companies to produce more to ease those
prices i know but have no fear
joe has a solution this solution will
allow you to save up to 80
per month at the pump and all you've got
to do
is buy a new electric car
under my plan
which is before the congress now we can
take advantage of the next generation of
electric vehicles
that a typical driver will save about 80
a month from not having to pay gas at
the pump
now 80 a month is pretty good you have
to buy a new car sure that's expensive
but 80 a month that's pretty good so if
you bought say a tesla model x
it's a pretty prominent new electric car
that costs 106
190 dollars to buy which is
expensive
but when you factor in the savings of 80
per month then that car will actually
pay for itself in
1328 months or roughly 111 years so just
you drive the car for 111 years and then
you're fine then you're good thank you
joe biden
you could get a less expensive model if
you would prefer you don't want to go
all the way for the model x okay you
could get a tesla model 3 that costs
forty five thousand one hundred ninety
dollars
that means that as long as you drive
that car
for 47 years you will really see some
some real savings at the pump and let's
say forget about tesla look michael
tesla that's a high-end company there's
got to be a cheaper electric car there
is there's the absolute cheapest
electric car that you could go out and
buy that's the nissan leaf that costs 28
425 dollars which means you can start
saving money after just 30 short years
this is great you're fine stop blaming
joe biden
unless you want to keep your car unless
you want to keep driving your car and
not go out and buy a new car in which
case
tough luck
i'm glad you like that clip now please
subscribe
ring that bell get the notifications
head on over to apple podcast spotify
stitcher google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review if you wouldn't mind and you can
also check out fauci unmasked that's my
three-part docu-series on that little
jerk dr fauci you can get that at
dailywire.com we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you